hey what's up folks down your dryer here
with Peter Brad hey I'm great you're a
big fan of doom you're also a longtime
fan of the Metal Gear Solid franchise
and here we have two items which you've
purchased for yourself this is the
collector's edition
official guide yeah and this is the the
collectors edition proper yeah and
there's an arm in here okay well we'll
get to the arm later first of all I want
to check out this no it's just a
strategy guide but I mean this is a game
with a lot of stuff to do in it and this
shows you how to get 100% of it like a
lot of guides but there's also a lot of
cool stuff in here that you don't get
otherwise like okay big maps together
yeah an epigraph from Yoji Shinkawa the
artist behind this series I'm going to
presume he made this one especially for
me okay so thank you should conversation
did you make this map of Afghanistan for
you no don't be crazy every home should
have one of those but yeah there's also
a 50-page section of art in the back
with comments on that's cool arias
things yeah so you got our burnishing
kala
like he is the mechanics designer and
the character designer and just the art
director in general you got concept art
for different worlds this is all Phantom
Pain's regram zeroes in here at all or
it's a good question I haven't had a
whole lot of time look through it but it
looks like it's often in pain there's
some stuff in here that's like oh super
dark oh that's it might be a little
splattering oh but you know no this is
just a really robust strategy guide with
a nice hardcover backing that comes with
some cool stuff there's only 20 bucks
that's cool I'm super cheap on Amazon
he has gone to if you hate them to look
at that stuff at the front but let's go
into this guy speaking of big red arms
get it done get your get your big box
cutter and open that bad boy up okay I'm
gonna open this thing up and let's do it
it looks like it's leather yeah it goes
it's not oh I know I know we all wanted
to be there said that and how much was
this at this book $20 how much was this
collector's edition 100 of my dollars my
goodness this is a PlayStation 4 version
or yeah PlayStation 4 version yeah this
is not sent to us from Konami and I
can't believe I'm opening it because
it's the last collector's edition of
Metal Gear that's probably ever gonna be
made oh it's sold out but it's for the
good people
gamespot its own they want to see they
want to see your buyers are more sore
have ended really I just want to see the
arm I care about you people but I care
about the arm head BIG's Dion half-scale
okay Japan got a full-size arm god
dammit dare they which looks really cool
like wouldn't put next to a Playstation
4 it's taller than a Playstation 4 Wow
which isn't surprising because I think
most people's arms are what are gonna do
there we go here we go it was all for
the cardboard flap we're done thanks
everybody
there's some weird glue I'm sliding off
the plastic and cutting it because I'm
going to put it back on because I'm a
dork but at least I can admit that we do
live close to the beach so there's
probably send gonna get up there's
definitely sand and a wind by my house
this isn't leather but it kind of feels
like it feels good to the touch it's
very good others I got glue on my box
got the Diamond Dogs embossed oh it
opens weird oh it's just skin er oh my
god it's cousin freakish it's not that
the length is weird it's that the what
get to the armistice I said this is the
pair of pain doesn't say day one edition
on it done a lot that's okay though
because I think that makes the cover
look ugly you know it also doesn't say
what Hideo Kojima game oh it does not it
does not say I do could you be game did
the day one edition and say that I don't
think oh but he's not he's in the game
and all that he's literally and he's
literally in the game you can get him
from other place and they do say hey I
could Jamie game in the game how do I
get this there's like a steelbook case
in here is I'm gonna take this part at
all right I'll take at this hand
situation there's so many things to take
out here oh really
uh-huh
steelbook steelbook we all love steel
books because they don't scratch easy
and they look great in your shop with
all your other steel books and inside I
don't know what is on this this is right
yeah this is a blu-ray which the biggest
thing it says on it is spoiler warning
yeah it says the F is the fan of episode
Kingdom of the Flies contains many
critical spoilers from the game so
presumably there is some sort of story
bit on here that I should probably watch
when you said Kingdom of the Flies it
maybe think does that mean be mad
yeah I'm gonna check in on this and see
what is on here because that's it's
pretty curious so anything else in there
at all before we get to the main event
no actually you know what sorry I should
not be the one to open this this is your
item you purchased get your hands off my
arm all right
so Big Boss has a prosthetic arm Big
Boss being the main character in the
phantom pain and he's got a bionic arm
because he lost his real arm an accident
and this is why your fingernails kids
mmm no telling don't defile it this is
actually really creepy look I never cool
what's the range of movement on it you
got old fingers oh man I'm unbending
everything here twisting turning bending
flexing what other kind of can you do
yep sure can up there you go this is for
you Jim sterling not to you but
something you would like to do to
somebody else
here's named Konami vas we've also got
we can go for go for radical like like
rock I guess metal finger there sorry
you can bend parts of his finger out I'm
not even sure I can do there you go or
we can go for like surfer version I
guess where it's like yeah brah
I guess maybe not I think Danny should
have bought this because he's having way
more famous oh my god you can rotate it
that way doesn't Arif I be not seen in
the game how instead of knocking on
walls now you spin your wrist around
clicker noise data terrifies me every
time yeah it's like he's triple-jointed
yeah there you go what do you think of
your hand your arm I guess I said before
it's pretty creepy
it's a very unusual items like a baby's
arm yeah i don't know i this is a this
is a collector's edition of a video game
in 2015 there you go yeah so for more
coverage of prosthetics for species how
various shapes and sizes and of course
video games and stay tuned to get sports
hot girl nice to meet you
like shaking a child's I like it it's
stronger than baby that's cool